- I don't want to talk
about politics tonight.
(audience laughs)
One side is very pro-gun, the
other side is very anti-gun.
I don't think they thought
through that strategy.
(audience laughs)
Women sports, still way
too competitive for me.
So what I think I'm
gonna start doing
is identifying as a kid,
start playing peewee football.
(audience laughs)
And I think gluten is the
Donald Trump of the food world.
A lot of people say
they're intolerant.
Most of those people go home
and crave it, don't they?
Joe Biden died two years ago.
Do y'all ever see the
movie Weekend at Bernie's?
Push him out on stage. "Uh,
time to give a speech, Joe."
(mumbles)
(audience cheers)
I remember, one of my best
friends on the planet,
he directed this special,
his name's Brent Pella.
He and I were in San
Diego doing shows
for a weekend late
last year and I said,
"Bro, I don't... I'm
ready to do a special.
I want to, I don't think I can."
Obviously, the typical
places, Netflix's and Amazons,
given the nature of the
content I'm doing on stage,
they're not gonna have it.
It's just way removed from
the mainstream narrative.
I couldn't even
release it on YouTube
for free if I wanted to.
That would get my channel
deleted like that.
(relaxed music)
- I'm Dave Rubin, and joining
me today is a comedian
whose new standup special.
"Please Censor This!"
is out now exclusively
on Locals, JP Sears.
I don't know how this
hasn't happened before,
but finally, welcome
to "The Rubin Report".
- Right on.
Well, thank you for
having me, Dave,
and it's been a pleasure
to meet you in person
a couple times and
I'm glad to be invited
to the sacred garden
of the Rubin Report.
(Dave laughs)
- I honestly don't know how
this hasn't happened before.
We've bumped into each other
many times over the years
at a lot of libertarian
events, a lot of places
where people are
carrying American flags
like right behind
you back there.
I obviously, I wanna
get into the special
and talk comedy
and all that stuff,
but I guess first, people
don't associate comedians
with freedom anymore, which
is a very bizarre thing.
Were you always kind
of libertarian-ish,
freedom focused,
blah, blah, blah?
Or was it a bit of
a pushback against
all the woke insanity over
the last couple years?
- Yeah, I wasn't
always this way.
It been a bit of a pushback.
I mean, look, just like
so many other people,
and I'll admit it, I was
living in a bubble of ignorance
and entitlement, just thinking,
well, this is America.
Like, why you don't need
to worry about freedom?
Like we can take it
for granted. Surprise.
It turns out that's
not the case.
And I don't like that I lived
in the bubble of ignorance,
but I did until our freedom
started getting taken away.
And you just see, if you
study patterns of history,
you see where it could
go if we allow it.
So that helped me realize
freedom's my number one value,
everything great in
life depends on freedom.
And, my child being able
to have a great life
and his children one
day, they need freedom.
So I used to just never
be in the politics,
couldn't even tell you
what the difference between
a democrat and a republican was.
But looking back,
I could see, yeah,
I leaned liberal and it was
kind of cool, but not anymore.
I have freedom.
(both laugh)
- Yeah, well, we played a little
bit of the standup special
as the cold open for the show,
and I'm sure most of my
audience knows you from YouTube
and Rumble and elsewhere.
Are you surprised that
so many comics went woke?
I mean, there are a ton
of guys I talk about
on the show all the time, who
I used to love and admire,
who were my comic influences,
some of them my friends
who then just went
off the deep end
with this woke,
politically correct,
I mean, that's
the danger really.
Not just woke, but
politically correct
and language freezing stuff
that has led us to all this.
- To be honest with you,
I have been surprised
that so many comedians
have gone woke
because, I think of a comedian
as sort of the rebel against
the system, the
system of corruption.
I think the most important
thing about comedy
is the truth principle.
So at its core, I consider
comedians to be people
who represent truth and
they do it in a fun way
and be goofy and
insane along the way.
So, as you see a lot of
people in the country
go woke, I would've
expected a lesser percentage
of comedians to do that.
I can understand why
they might, I mean
I think if someone outsources
their power and success
to other people,
whether it's a audience,
a network or trying
to get picked up by
some kind of agency,
I can see that that's my only
hypothesis why someone would
abandon the truth
principle and cater
to political correctness
when they're comedians.
So I'm not totally sure,
but that's my hypothesis
on why some haven't by
the way, and the ones
who haven't, man, they're like,
it's a great time for
business, for comedians
who just wanna represent
the truth no matter
who's speaking the hypocrisies.
And I watch Ryan
Long, Tyler Fisher,
these guys who just
shoot straight arrows
and it's great and I think it's,
I love seeing a lot of
people discover them because
there's not a lot of competition
for unwoke comedians.
Jim Brewer is certainly
in that category.
He's been huge for
forever though.
- I opened for Jim Brewer at
Carolines in New York City,
probably 2002,
- No kidding.
- Another lifetime ago.
He was taking bong hits in the
green room before the show,
and he hands me the bong
and I'm like, I, dude,
this is like my,
it was like my first like
big break or something.
I was like, I am not taking
a bong hit before I walk out.
And he crushed it. The guy
was baked out of his mind.
He absolutely crushed it.
(JP laughing)
- That's hilarious.
- So, okay, so the
title of the special
is "Please Censor This!".
And I thought that that
was particularly Apropobe
because you launched on Locals,
which obviously everyone knows.
I started Locals as
a wall in essence
against big tech censorship.
Did you think about releasing,
exclusively on YouTube
or just there's a litany
of places where you could
have done it, but
you did it with us.
So I'm pretty happy about that.
- Yeah, I thought about
all the possibilities
and to be honest with you, Dave,
for a while I thought
it was defeated.
There was a lot of adversity
to bring this special
to the world and the times
of censorship we live in.
And I remember the, one of my
best friends on the planet,
he directed this special,
his name's Brent Pella
he and I were in San Diego
doing shows for a weekend
late last year and I said,
"Bro, I don't, I'm ready to do
a special, I want to,
I don't think I can."
Obviously the typical places
Netflix's and Amazon's,
given the nature of the
content I'm doing on stage,
they're not gonna have it.
It's just way removed from
the mainstream narrative.
I couldn't even release
it on YouTube for free
if I wanted to, that would get
my channel deleted like that.
And then my, Brent
he's like a wise sage,
he said, "JP, do you know how
much of an idiot you are?"
I said, "Kind of,
but tell me more."
And he said, "you don't
need a distributor like you,
you've got a 6 million
person audience.
Quit thinking in the
old paradigm, you
are the distributor."
So that really helped
me open my eyes.
And then along the way,
the idea of like, well,
let's reach out to
Locals and Rumble,
see if we can do some
kind of partnership
to just get this thing
out to the world.
And that value alignment
about what I stand for,
what the comedy in
the special represents
and what Locals
represents, it's just that
was perfect value alignment.
And it's just been such
a joy to get this special
out to the world, I
think in a beautiful way.
If I did it completely
independently
had some sort of weird
servers in my garage
(Dave laughing)
to house the special,
and I'm screwing stuff up
I would've been
proud to do that.
But it's just great to get it
out with a very established,
beautiful platform that actually
brings a community together.
I love that aspect, that's
been such a great bonus.
- Oh, well I'm
thrilled to hear that.
I mean, and that's exactly
what it's all about.
We want people that
have audiences,
whether they're
comedians or actors
or politicians or shoe salesmen.
We want them to be able
to reach their people
and we just give you
the tools to do it.
And then you go from there.
Are you like completely
out of whatever would
be considered the
LA comedy world?
I've cut ties with CAA,
I have nothing to
do with it anymore.
Are you like just completely
outta that world altogether?
- Yeah, I would say
I'm very much removed
from the Hollywood
world in the sense
of I have nothing on
my bucket list that
involves Hollywood whatsoever.
Occasionally I'll get
people reaching out,
they're doing an
independent film and like me
to consider a part in that.
And I'm willing to consider
it because it's independent.
There's not some big woke
China backed BS, ESG entity
behind it, so I'm,
I love creativity
and I love what I stand for.
So when there's value alignment,
I'm willing to consider,
oh, an independent
film, things like that.
But the beautiful thing
is life is so great,
I get so much fulfillment
connecting with people,
releasing weekly videos, doing
my standup, having my family.
So there's nothing
else that I need.
And man, I'll tell you, it's
so great to be completely
un-enslaved to the
Hollywood system
and those kind of powerhouses
where you see what happens
what people do to
themselves to stay in line.
- It's a freaking,
- They summersault
they abandon their principles
and that's no way to live.
- No. And then you've got, we've
done a bunch on him lately.
You've got guys like
Jimmy Kimmel who used
to be politically incorrect
and, doing all of that stuff.
Carl Malone and
Blackface, et cetera.
And now he's the most woke
politically correct person.
There is. It's a
real flip on things.
- Isn't it mind boggling?
And you mentioned Jimmy
Kimmel, Howard Stern
I mean these people, who
- oh, that's the one.
- They gained admiration
because of their balls
and wittiness for standing
up against the establishment.
I'm not like stand up
against the establishment
just to do it, but like
corruption and establishment
taking advantage of
people, that kind of thing.
But now you see these
guys, they're like, "Oh,
dude these checks
are pretty large.
Maybe we'll become
the establishment."
It's just a weird mutation
to see in front of our eyes.
- And you see it
with so many of them.
I mean, Sarah Silverman's
another one, like these people
who were, they were
edgy, like they went for
it's not just like, "Oh,
I was kind of like out
there a little," I'm talking
like the fringe case edgy
comedians who then became
the most politically correct.
It's, I could do
all day on that.
Do you ever long for
the old days of comedy?
Like if you were to open
up my YouTube on my TV,
I'm watching old Johnny Carson.
I'm watching all the legends
of years long gone by.
But the idea that you could do
stand up for a couple years,
you get that five minutes,
you sit down with Carson,
you get the sick.
There was something really
nice to the machine.
As beautiful as all this freedom
is, where in our day it's
like there is nobody to go to.
There's nobody's that I
don't care to be on Kimmel or
Colbert or anything else,
which is exactly
what you're saying.
- Yeah.
- But there was a
magic to it in a way.
- Yeah. There's the nostalgia
that was the olden days
and I was never a professional
comedian during that time.
So it's just all
looking back and I think
it's a cool time
to reminisce about,
but there's no part of me
that wishes it was that day,
outside of like
the cool moments.
Like if you got to sit down
with Carson, like, dude,
of course, like that's amazing.
But there was so much
outsourced power then,
people couldn't take control
of their own destiny.
And I think self
responsibility is the
greatest superpower people have.
I think it's the
most underutilized
power in our country.
People are waking
up to it, luckily.
But I love the idea of like,
now you take destiny
in your own hands.
If you work hard,
you're consistent,
you put stuff out online.
If you're consistent with it
and you have some level of DNA
to actually do comedy, you
will build an audience.
You will, whether it's
big, small, fast, low,
that's a variable, but
nobody needs to wait
around being discovered
by the industry anymore.
So I just love the empowerment
aspect of how it is today
that censorships dragon in that.
But for aside from that,
we have a lot of power
in our hands and I love it.
- Yeah. And it's on
you and it's like
if you work harder and you
get better at your craft
some good things
will probably happen.
Not always, but I'd rather
it be on me than on an agent
or on a machinery
that I can't control.
Let me, let's jump off
comedy for just a sec
cuz you are in Texas.
- Yeah.
- But you are in the Austin
area of Texas, the weird area.
- Yeah.
- And when I talk to
other people from Texas,
let's say my friends at
the Blaze over in Dallas,
they often wonder what the
high hell's going on in Austin.
So what is it like to be in
a sort of blueish area in a
state that hopefully is
about to go even redder?
We'll see what happens
over the next couple days.
- Yeah. But we'll redder
the better in my opinion.
And that's not just my ginger
lights politics talking Dave.
(Dave laughing)
- By the way, the hair matching
the flag behind you, really.
- Thank you. I'm grateful,
I was born in America,
sucked to be born in Ukraine
with incompatible flag colors.
I love Austin. Austin has
some of the best people
who are purpose driven,
soulful, and really going after
their dreams and contributing
to a better world.
Now there's certainly some
leftist stuff about how the city
of Austin is run that
I don't agree with.
And you certainly get some,
plenty of eyes glazed over
mass formation, hip
psychosis addicts.
But you know what I actually
kinda like that Dave,
because nobody, I think
maybe we all wanna live
in an echo chamber, but one
of the worst things for us
would be to just live
in an echo chamber.
So I, true diversity
in my opinion,
is having a diversity of
perspectives and I like that.
But at the same time,
because Austin is in Texas,
there's plenty of
like-minded people.
I've talked to people
all over the country
and one of the biggest
pains that folks report
is I feel like I'm the only one
someone living in San
Francisco, Portland,
so there's a lot
of community here.
And a few months ago
we moved to a ranch
about an hour outside of Austin.
So now it's, I mean we're
in real Texas country now.
(both laughing)
So it's just, if
someone drives by,
we were just in downtown,
a town where we live
in a coffee shop and
someone drove by with a vote
for Bedo bumper sticker.
And it's just so cool how
like, dude, that's shocking.
We saw that out here.
- Yeah.
- Someone driving by with
a big Trump bumper sticker
in downtown Portland.
- It's funny cuz I'm here in
Florida, which is obviously
it's DeSantis country,
DeSantis stand depending
on who you talk to.
And there's one guy
in my neighborhood
with the Charlie Chris
sign, and it's like,
it actually, of course it
kind of seems funny to me,
but I keep thinking one day
I'm gonna be walking my dog
and I wanna meet this person
because what could possibly
be going on in their head
to live in the freest place
and not want that freedom.
However, I respect
their desire, of course,
to vote however they wish.
- Yeah. That I like to
understand what, like, cool,
why one of my best friends,
we were sitting around election
night about two years ago
and we're just talking like,
"Hey, here's who I voted for."
And just one person
outta the group said,
"Yeah, I voted for Biden."
And it was so cool to just want
to understand him and it was
a beautiful connective
conversation and
we didn't agree,
but that didn't mean
we had to divide
or not like each other.
It was very interesting
to learn, "Oh, that's why
you voted for Biden", by
the way, talk to him now.
And he is like,
"Dude, I regret it."
(both laughing)
- Him along with apparently
81 million other people.
I think a lot of the, I don't
know if all 81, but you know.
In terms of doing comedy for
let's say a more conservative
or libertarian minded crowd,
do you find that there are
rails that you can't touch on
that side that maybe
you wish you could touch
but you can't quite
get to because
of maybe more religious issues,
that kind of thing?
- I'm sure there's rails,
but I haven't hit them yet.
Just recently, I've
really noticed, especially
in my standup, I'm
shifting the material,
releases special and got now
generate a lot of new material
and I'm shifting the
material from doing,
sometimes bashing the
left as a butt of jokes
to now it's much more self
deprecating of a conservative,
libertarian minded
person, which is great.
I mean, I love to honor what
I love by making fun of it.
And also it's like, if you
can't laugh at yourself,
you've got problems.
So as I'm doing that, I
haven't found the rails yet
though in the past I
can say when before
I got into politics,
I'm doing standup
and I would do some level
of Jesus kind of joke there.
You can tell like, all right,
there's some folks who,
that was a hot button for
them and maybe it came across
disrespectfully, maybe
it was just a good joke
and they didn't like it.
I don't know. But
the past experiences,
I think the religious
piece probably is the
biggest challenge
when it comes to the
conservative crowd
to, dance well with
as opposed to just offend.
- Yeah, it's super
interesting because obviously
my credentials and biography
are not fully in line
with say what a
conservative audience
would be showing up to.
And yet I get nothing but
love from these people.
- Yeah.
- And even when I get close
to whatever that line might be
or say something that makes
them a little bit uncomfortable
that they haven't
thought about before,
it's like, it's all good.
There really is a sense
of like, it's all good.
Yeah, we get that, we can
all be a little bit different
and it's okay.
- Yeah. And I would guess
with people who watch you
see you and same with
me, they're watching us
because they already know us.
They love us, they
appreciate us.
So there's already
a big rapport built
out of the countless videos
of yours they've seen.
So there's that trust as
opposed to just a comedian fresh
off the street going
into the showroom,
the audience doesn't know
who they are, less trust.
So they can probably
get away with less
because they just don't
know exactly where
that person's heart is.
But they know where
your heart is,
they know where my heart is.
- How many years did you spend
grinding through the clubs?
I did it for a long time,
man, I started in May of 98
right after college, a week
after graduating college.
And I was doing standup for
many, for at least a decade,
like six nights a week.
And then the last couple
years before I left New York,
then I was a little bit less,
started getting into podcasting.
I saw the frontier, the
new frontier developing
eventually moved out
to LA now back here.
But how many years were
you like in the grind of,
you're one of 10 on the show,
they don't know who you are
by the time you get
going, you gotta
get off stage, et cetera?
- Zero.
(JP laughing)
Wow, I admire that.
- The route I took,
I so don't recommend,
but here's the route I took.
I got known on YouTube and
just online videos first.
So the audience was built up
and then I got into standup
and I had already sort of
been doing a bit of standup
before I knew it because
once I started getting known,
different conferences
would come in,
hire me to come in and speak.
And they're like, "Oh, why
don't you do some comedy?"
I'm like, well, "Cool
that makes sense."
So I was practicing it
for a while without having
it in the frame of
my mind as standup.
And so as I was
starting standup,
I already had an audience and
here's what I don't recommend,
I just jumped into the
deep end cuz I didn't know
any better, it's
like, "all right,
let's start
headlining shows now."
(Dave laughing)
And I'm doing five
shows in this city
rather than just starting slow.
So it was very stressful.
And also like, looking back
at my beginning standup,
I'd say like, I'm pretty
embarrassed about it.
- I mean, everybody
is of their old stuff.
That's how it is.
- Of course, so it was
good enough to give people
a value and they had
love, it was great,
but the standup sucked.
So it luckily though,
it was probably just
barely good enough that it
wasn't a complete train wreck
because jumping into the deep
end, starting the headline
pretty much right away,
it's not the recommended
course of action if
that gets derailed.
It's sort of like,
well, project failed.
So I had a bit of a
unique route, which again,
I don't recommend.
And honestly I didn't
even, I didn't know
how normal comedians
like started,
like I wasn't listening
to Joe Rogan's podcast,
how he talks about it.
I was just, ignorance is
bliss and here's the way
it's suggested to be
by some team members.
And I was like, "All
right, let's do that."
- It's so funny how
everyone's story
is a little bit
different because,
so when I started Carson
had retired already,
so Leno took over, but Leno
wasn't putting comics on
the way Carson was.
And I saw all of these guys
that I was coming up with
that all wanted to get
on the Tonight Show
and I was like,
But he's not really
putting anybody on
The Tonight Show.
He's not making stars
the way Carson is.
And then because of that,
after a couple years
I heard about this
thing called a podcast.
I didn't even know what it was.
I kid you not, did not
know how to download.
I didn't even know what it
was that was on the phone.
I wasn't even sure,
but I had a guy who
knew something about
audio and I started doing
a little podcast
early on and I think
I just followed that path.
So everyone either you
become the YouTube star first
and then you figure it out
after, or you just do it
any which way I guess that
gets to your freedom point
of doing something for yourself.
- Yeah. It's with
great freedom comes
great responsibility
and it's liberating
and it's also scary,
the scary part is
there's no definitive structure
that you need to walk on.
So there's less security,
there's less predictability,
there's probably a fair bit
more having to figure it out
and therefore probably make
a lot of errors and mistakes.
What year did you
start the podcast?
- I started in
98, 98, May of 98.
- No, you were doing
a podcast in 98?
- Oh, no, no, no, no,
started standup, sorry,
standup May of 98.
And then I started the
podcast, my first first podcast
probably 2006,
something like that.
Like this was.
- Still unbelievable.
I didn't even have the
internet at home in 2006.
You're doing a podcast.
- It was why I truly,
I had a microphone,
this big machine on the desk,
I don't know what
the hell I was doing.
And then suddenly I
was getting emails
and people were like,
I'm listening to it.
I did not even know how
to put it on my own phone.
I kid you not.
What do you make about,
so obviously this,
are we posting this before
or after the election?
I'm talking to my
guys while we're,
this is either going
up before or after
this coming election, but
we're taping it before
in full transparency.
Okay. So I'm just told
we're posting this after,
but we're taping this
before the election.
What do you make of
the general temperature
of the country right now?
- I'm shocked that it
doesn't seem more inflamed.
- That's interesting.
- And that's not to say
there's complete peace
by any stretch, but
I just think back to
the time before in the,
before the 2020 election
and then that space
between the election
and the inauguration.
Good lord, that
was a tense time.
Now I know this is not
a presidential election,
so that's part of it,
but when you look at all
the polling and it's like,
all right, we, something
weird really has to happen for
there not to be a huge red wave.
I'm surprised there's
not more BS happening.
I mean, we see the media
smearing manipulation,
like Donald Trump did
that to Paul Pelosi.
He's the one.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
They knew immediately
it was a maga person.
- Somehow they know.
- The nudist, the BLM nudist
that shows up at the house.
Yeah. Big maga person.
- Yeah. So I'm pleased with
how peaceful things have been.
I'm pleased that more
than any other election
that I can think of,
people seem to care.
They seem to be ready
to get out to vote,
which every way they
wanna vote, they know
we're living in
a time and place.
This the state of things,
this is not sustainable.
They know things need to change.
So I love seeing the
motivation happening as well.
And then, looking at
the different races,
there's hilarious
stuff going on.
Like cool, the Fetterman debate.
I thought Biden
was fun to watch.
He's got nothing on
Fetterman, that's a joy.
(Dave laughing)
So yeah, I think
it's a cool time and
I hope things are
straightforward,
honest with results
and yeah, I have
hoped that we'll have
continued relative peace rather
than escalated inflammation.
But one thing I will say if
I wanted to be pessimistic is
I would be worried about
what the media will do.
If things don't go their
way and it's looking like
it's not gonna go the way
the mainstream media tries
to sway things, you just
never know what they'll do
to try to manipulate
people who are no longer
being manipulated by them.
I mean, what kind of fear
mongering, smears, lies
I mean, we've seen it all.
So how much worse could
it get? I don't know,
but maybe worse.
- Yeah. Well it's
interesting because
before you were saying how,
comedy it's so connected
to truth or it should
be so connected to truth
and it's like, man, the
media, I always say it's like,
you guys don't have to be great,
but just don't be
completely horrible.
But they seem unable, I
mean, almost completely
without exception, there's
a couple exceptions
unable to stop themselves
and stop relying on the,
like they're just so in on it.
They're in on the
big lie, so to speak.
- They are, aren't they?
And I think given their jobs,
now we know the narrative
of what their job is.
Journalists, that's
not the reality.
Their jobs are giving
polarized opinions
and we know the polarized
opinions are always
heavily leaning left.
So a golden retriever
wants to retrieve, period,
and the media wants
to propagandize.
That's what they do.
So, I honestly, I
pray for those people.
I certain, cuz they're all
good people at heart, I think.
Their behavior isn't, but
I pray for those people
that they connect to a
greater sense of purpose.
That I mean one of the
greatest gifts we can have
is the fulfillment we
get by contributing
to the betterment of
another person or people.
Now they do the
opposite of that,
but I just pray for them that,
they make some choices
that allow themselves
to get fulfilled.
Like Carrie Lake's story
is so inspiring for me.
She was so successful in
the media, but she couldn't,
she just couldn't take the
idea of lies, lies, lies.
She couldn't take the
feeling of unfulfillment.
So she made a different choice
and now she's really doing
a great job of working
on contributing to
the betterment of
a lot of people.
- Yeah, it's interesting.
I mean we talk about
it on the show a lot.
It's like we can all focus
on politics all the time,
but this isn't exactly
a political problem.
It's a spiritual problem
or a personal problem.
And if we can solve that
at the ground level,
then maybe we can
solve the rest of it.
- Yeah, I think we need a,
I think before any
politician goes into office,
they need to do some
deep inner child work.
(Dave laughing)
It's, you can quit compensating
for how unloved you felt
as a kid or abuse you
might have went through.
You can quit
compensating for that.
You're probably gonna be
doing a lot better job,
be a lot less corrupt,
a lot less control
and power hungry and
more service oriented.
- It's funny, even hearing
you say that, obviously
I here in Florida, I love
DeSantis, but it's not,
I always say it's
not because of like
that I worship politicians.
It's like he's a guy who
happened to step into this thing
and then has fought
for our freedoms.
He's not out there
like, you owe me this,
this is the power
I want over you.
I think whether
he knew it or not,
he did some of that,
that child work.
Some of that inner child stuff.
- I wouldn't be
surprised and DeSantis
served in the military,
so he's got perspective
of what really matters.
I don't know his exact
military field experiences,
but he's probably had
things put in perspective.
And I think when people have
things put into perspective,
for me, having my son
was a big piece of that.
You realize how much power
and control just don't matter.
There's such a worthless
currency compared
to the currency
of connection,
contribution, joy, I mean,
hell even laughter
for that matter.
So some of my favorite
politicians are the ones
that don't want
to be politicians.
They're called to do
it in order to serve.
- JP I give you my word that
Locals will never censor you.
(both laughing)
That's number one.
Number two, we're gonna
link to the special
right down below.
And this will either go
down as a great interview
or a completely haywire
interview depending
on what happens
during the election
since we're taping it before
and releasing it after
but we ain't editing
it either way.
So we'll see what happens.
- we should do two versions
where we make predictions
just so we can look
at like psychics.
- JP Sears, thank you my friend.
Good to see you.
- Great to see you, Dave.
Thank you for having me.
- If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful
conversations about comedy
instead of the nonstop yelling
you get everywhere else
check out our comedy playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, check
out our full episode playlist.
They're both right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.